and now it's time for Quebec corner with
your humble and Johnny please welcome to
Quebec corner
I'm euros the ad-hoc Shambo in the I'm
is a brother yes II bought it I don't
want to put a body that's better
my amazing you people that OMA been
asking us does Quebec corner like the
Christmas does Quebec we live the
Christmas Sookie we live for it that's
like asking his GSP gonna be Matthews
they're gonna find out for time and open
look come let me see this Christmas tree
look we have it yes I think yes in our
basement all year long we keep it's a
good looking stuff I all all that time
and our art the Christmas yeah that's
the kind of Safa you have been shopping
a mind kids they're gonna tell Santa
what they want that's a fine we just
want to tell you people's at home from
Quebec corner we wish you a Merry
Christmas by we we really gonna want to
gonna you know for that's the still not
I don't string or nothing
what sake what's our yeah no baby oh I
could see no well but thought oh gosh
man we're we come to sing like doc slack
that's why you're at Quebec corner we
want to wish you a happy holiday and
then I don't think that works like that
no happy on the car Mary Kwanzaa marry
Dorothy Beke one-dab America
that's that's the Jewish one that's the
black one we want to wish you a happy
nondescript celebration in December most
likely because that's what the
Babylonian celebrate the winter solstice
they can enact laws in a way I know it's
Christmas I know it's the regulation no
no no you're American you mess up
everything good someone wish you Merry
Christmas is not bad when they say that
I know oke no it's enough finally oke
you gonna have some eggnog some some
some lava Toki it's a celebration you
guys in a marriage you get so mad upset
uptight about these things
you have your Rolls Royce your penthouse
in the Upper West Side enjoy your
Christmas don't ruin it for everybody
else Cheech Richard was the better
watham in shows Quebec Commodore a
National Center I put on a lots of
videos for you this year if you wanna
have more of that you can give them
money the National Center the orgy and
the money is tax deductible they get
nothing is that the doctor Bowl for the
peoples who donate during the month of
December we're going to send you a
Polaroid how to laugh at you know PR
junkie I'm gonna blow on it personally
we know Christmas could be very
difficult for us to the mall no the
shopping the president stressful at the
maze it's important for you to remember
what Christmas is all about
can anybody tell me what Christmas is
all about
well watch the Charlie Brown that's it
that's it that's it
Cabo Saba come see those sequins